this is a Fox News Alert Senator Lindsey
Graham tonight introducing a new
resolution condemning the House of
Representatives their closed-door
illegitimate unconstitutional
impeachment inquiry he joins us now with
more senator I'm glad to see this happen
censure every Republican that was there
voted for it yesterday Democrats shut it
down never before has this happened in
an impeachment inquiry closed doors they
won't even they won't let a Republican
read a transcript without a a minder and
God forbid they get a copy of it yes so
this resolution puts the Senate on
record condemning the house for the
future of the presidency we cannot allow
future presidents in this president to
be impeached based on an inquiry in the
house has never been voted upon that
does not allow the President to confront
the witnesses against him call witnesses
on his behalf and cross-examine people
are accusing him of misdeeds all I'm
asking is give Donald Trump the same
rights as Richard Nixon and Bill Clinton
had when it comes to impeachment and I'm
insisting that Donald Trump be given the
same rights every American has if you're
given a parking ticket to confront the
witnesses against you can't be based on
hearsay and here's the point of the
resolution any impeachment vote based on
this process to me is illegitimate it's
unconstitutional and should be dismissed
in the Senate without a trial okay now
let's walk through how that gets done
how do you dismiss it without a trial
all of what you're saying is true Newt
Gingrich will join us in a minute he
will explain to us in detail every
consideration look I'll quote you in
this whole thing every he said the
cornerstone of America's jurisprudence
due process you said the right to
confront your accusers or call witnesses
on your behalf
challenge the accusations against you
none of that is happening in the House
of Representatives and where you fellow
senators I'd like to see them sign your
letter well I well it's going to be a
resolution I hope to have a vote on it I
hope I can get you to be great to have a
hundred can you imagine if Republicans
we're doing this to a Democratic
president this hole this this opening
statement
by Bill Taylor today everybody is
breathless here's a question why does
the president the Ukraine deny there's a
quid pro quo what do you know that he
doesn't know why did the president the
Ukraine say during the phone call I
didn't know aid was suspended and the
president of Ukraine the alleged victim
of all this denies that there was a quid
pro quo he didn't feel threatened by the
president the United States that only
happens if you can confront the
witnesses against you this process in
the house is being conducted behind
closed doors Republicans are being shut
out and if you had an inquiry vote that
allows Republicans and the president to
call witnesses and to confront people
accusing the president of misdeeds
that's what happened with Clinton that's
what happened with Nixon and Andrew
Johnson this is unamerican and its core
what the House of Representatives is
doing is a process of political revenge
it is alien to American due process it
should be dismissed quickly in the
United States Senate so what would
happen if they impeach the president
based on this closed-door
behind-the-scenes lack of due process
inquiry we should dismiss it without a
trial because it's illegitimate on its
face and if it is allowed to stand
there's no protection for future
presidents when the president says and
we went over this my opening monologue
tonight when a president says can you do
me a favor now we've identified hundreds
of times that is that happens to be one
of the presidents transition phrases and
we have the tape could you do me a favor
then he talks about the 2016 election
interference of Ukraine confirmed by
Politico January 11 2017 isn't also one
of his constitutional duties as sworn
oath to faithfully execute the laws of
the land and I just heard everyone so
upset about election interference with
Trump and Russia I would think they'd be
on board wanting to help Trump get to
the truth but that's not the case is it
now when Democrat has suggested the
president Trump is being treated
unfairly when it violates every basic
principle of due process we gave about
four hundred million dollars a year to
the Ukraine and in aid so here's the
question is the political article
Politico article accurate is somebody
looking at DNC involvement with Ukraine
in 2016 look as they looked at Trump in
Russia
somebody needs to do that so it's not
unfounded for the president to be
concerned about Ukrainian interference
in our election if you believe the 26 if
you believe the political article but
here's the point we're talking about
impeaching the president United States
destroying a mandate from the people a
political death sentence and he is not
entitled to know who his accusers are he
can't call a witness on his behalf and
he can't cross-examine those who are
coming forward and it's all done behind
closed door with doors without public
scrutiny this is illegitimate thank you
sir
I hope the rest of the Senate follows
you